On January 26 2013 a band of al-qaida
militants entered the ancient city of
Timbuktu on the southern edge of the
Sahara Desert there they set fire to a
medieval library of thirty thousand
manuscripts written in Arabic and
several African languages and ranging in
subject from astronomy to geography
history to medicine including one book
which records perhaps the first
treatment for male erectile disfunction
unknown in the West
this was the collected wisdom of an
entire continent the voice of Africa at
a time when Africa was thought not to
have a voice at all the mayor of Bamako
who witnessed the event called the
burning of the manuscripts a crime
against world cultural heritage and he
was right or he would have been if it
weren't for the fact that he was also
lying in fact just before African
scholars had collected a random
assortment of old books and left them
out for the terrorists to burn today the
collection lies hidden in Bamako the
capital of Mali moldering in the high
humidity what was rescued by ruse is now
once again in jeopardy this time by
climate but Africa and the far-flung
corners of the world are not the only
places or even the main places in which
manuscripts that could change the
history of world culture are in jeopardy
several years ago I conducted a survey
of European research libraries and
discovered that at the barest minimum
there are 60,000 manuscripts pre 1500
that are illegible because of water
damage
fading mold and chemical reagents the
real number is likely double that and
that doesn't even count
Renaissance manuscripts and modern
manuscripts and cultural heritage
objects such as maps
what if there were a technology that
could recover these lost and unknown
works imagine worldwide how a trove of
hundreds of thousands of previously
unknown texts could radically transform
our knowledge the past imagine what
unknown classics we would discover which
would rewrite the canons of literature
history philosophy music or more
provocatively that could rewrite our
cultural identities building new bridges
between people and culture these are the
questions that transform me from a
medieval scholar a reader of texts into
a textual scientist what an unsatisfying
word reader is for me it conjures up
images of passivity of someone sitting
idly in an armchair waiting for
knowledge to come to him in a neat
little parcel how much better to be a
participant in the past a adventure in
an undiscovered country searching for
the hidden text as an academic I was a
mere reader I read and taught the same
classics that people had been reading
and teaching for hundreds of years
Virgil Ovid Chaucer Petrarch and with
every scholarly article that I published
I added to human knowledge and ever
diminishing slivers of insight what I
wanted to be was an archaeologist of the
past a discoverer of literature in
Indiana Jones without the whip or
actually with the quim and I wanted it
not just for myself but I wanted for my
students as well and so six years ago I
changed the direction of my career at
the time I was working on the chest of
love the last important long poem of the
European Middle Ages never to have been
edited and it wasn't edited because it
existed in only one manuscript which was
so badly damaged during the firebombing
of Dresden in world war ii that
generations of scholars had pronounced
it lost for five years I had been
working with an ultraviolet lamp trying
to recover traces of it writing and I'd
gone about as far as technology at the
time could actually take me and so I did
what many people do I went online and
there I learned about how multispectral
imaging had been used to recover two
lost treatises of the famed Greek
mathematician Archimedes from a 13th
century palimpsest the palimpsest is a
manuscript which has been erased and
overwritten and so out of the blue I
decided to write to the lead imaging
scientist on the Arkham used Archimedes
palimpsest project Professor Roger
Easton with a plan and a plea and to my
surprise he actually wrote back with his
help I was able to win a grant from the
US government to build a transportable
multispectral imaging lab and with this
lab I transformed what was a charred and
faded mess into a new medieval classic
so how does multi spectral imaging
actually work well the idea behind multi
spectral imaging is that it's something
that anyone who's familiar with infrared
night-vision goggles will immediately
appreciate that what we can see in the
visible spectrum of light is only tiny
fraction of what's actually there the
same is true with invisible writing our
system uses twelve wavelengths of light
between the ultraviolet and the infrared
and these are shown down onto the
manuscript from above from banks of LEDs
and another multi spectral light source
which comes up through the individual
leaves manuscript up to 35 images per
sequence per leaf our image this way
using a high-powered digital camera
equipped with a lens which is made out
of quartz they're about five of these in
the world and once we capture these
images we feed them through statistical
algorithms to further enhance and
clarify them using software which was
originally designed for satellite images
and used by people like geospatial juice
facial scientists and the CIA the
results can be spectacular you may
already have heard of what's been done
for the Dead Sea Scrolls which are
slowly gelatinizing using infrared we've
been able to read even the darkest
corners of the Dead Sea Scrolls you may
not be aware however of other biblical
texts that are in jeopardy here for
example is a leaf from a manuscript that
we
imaged which is perhaps the most
valuable Christian Bible in the world
the codex waggle Ensis is the oldest
translation of the gospels into latin
and it dates from the first half of the
fourth century this is the closest we
can come to the Bible at the time of the
foundation of Christendom under Emperor
Constantine and at the time of also the
Council of Nicaea when the basic Creed
of Christianity was being agreed upon
this manuscript unfortunately has been
very badly damaged and it's damaged
because for centuries it has been used
and handled in swearing-in ceremonies in
the church in fact that purple splash
that you see in the upper left-hand
corner is Aspergillus which is a fungus
which originates in the unwashed hands
of a person with tuberculosis our
imaging has enabled me to make the first
transcription of this manuscript in 250
years having a lab that can travel to
collections where it's needed however is
only part of the solution the technology
is expensive and very rare and the
imaging and image processing skills are
esoteric that means that mounting
Recovery's is beyond the reach of most
researchers and all but the wealthiest
institutions that's why I founded the
Lazarus project but not for profit
initiative to bring multispectral
imaging to individual researchers and
smaller institutions at little or no
cost whatsoever over the past five years
our team of imaging scientists scholars
and students has traveled to seven
different countries and have recovered
some of the world's most valuable
damaged manuscripts including the
vercelli book which is the oldest book
of English the black book of Carr Martin
the oldest book of Welsh and some of the
most valuable earliest Gospels located
in now what's the former Soviet Georgia
so spectral imaging can recover lost
texts more subtly though it can recover
a second story behind every object the
story of how when and by whom a text was
created and
sometimes what the author was thinking
at the time he wrote take for example a
draft of the Declaration of Independence
written in Thomas Jefferson's own hand
which some colleagues of mine imaged a
few years ago at the Library of Congress
curators had noticed that one word
throughout had been scratched out and
overwritten the word overwritten was
citizens perhaps you can guess what the
word underneath was subjects there
ladies and gentlemen is American
democracy evolving under the hand of
Thomas Jefferson or consider the 1491
Martellus map which we imaged at Yale's
by Nikki library this was the map that
Columbus likely consulted before he
traveled to the new world and which gave
him his idea of what Asia looked like
and where Japan was located the problem
with this map is that its inks and
pigments had so degraded over time that
this large nearly seven foot map made
the world look like a giant desert until
now we had very little idea detailed
idea that is of what Columbus knew of
the world and how world cultures
represented the main legend of the map
was entirely illegible under normal
light ultraviolet didn't very little for
it multi-spectral
gave us everything in asia we learned of
monsters with ears so long that they
could cover the creatures entire body in
Africa about a snake who could cause the
ground to smoke like starlight which can
give a images the way the universe
looked in the distant past so multi
spectral light can take us back to the
first stuttering moments of an object's
creation through this lens we witness
the mistakes the changes of mind the
naivete is the uncensored thoughts the
imperfections of the human imagination
that allow these hallowed objects and
their authors to become more real that
make history closer to us what about the
future there's so much of the past and
so few people with the skills to rescue
it before these objects disappear
forever
that's why I've begun to teach this new
hybrid discipline that I call textual
science
actual science is a marriage of the
traditional skills of a literary scholar
the ability to read old languages and
old handwriting the knowledge of how
texts are made in order to be able to
place and date them with new techniques
like imaging science the chemistry of
inks and pigments computer-aided optical
character recognition last year a
student my class a freshman with a
background in Latin in Greek was image
processing a palimpsest that we had
photographed at a famous library in Rome
as he worked tiny Greek writing began to
appear from behind the text everyone
gathered around and he read a line from
a lost work of the Greek comic dramatist
Menander
this was the first time in well over a
thousand years that those words had been
pronounced aloud in that moment he
became a scholar ladies and gentlemen
that is the future of the past thank you
very much